welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for she-hulk on disney plus
starring tatiana maslany as jennifer
walters attorney at law cousin to bruce
banner and uh someone for whom my
admiration i swear to you remains to
wholesome professional respect anyone
complaining about the cgi we just may be
better off in the uncanny valley right
now because uh if this looked too
lifelike major portions of the
productivity in america would have come
to a screeching halt when this trailer
dropped from the return of tim roth as a
male polanski abomination to frogman
sightings and precisely why the cgi
might be a little off in some spots i'm
gonna break down this trailer frame by
frame for the details that you missed
let's go
being a superhero
a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world if not
people like you
[Music]
so we open on the la skyline already a
bit of a change to the pace for the mcu
which hasn't really been in the modern
day la area since iron man 3. we hear
the voice of bruce banner giving the
hero talk to his cousin jennifer as a
fancy event comes under siege this
actually looks like the event that jen
later in this trailer attends in her
nice dress and now outside we see these
armored soldiers carrying these
interesting looking weapons these
actually look like a smaller handout
version of the sonic cannons that
general ross used on hulk in the 2008
film which according to that movie's
opening credits actually came from a
stark industry's design they showed up
later equipped on the stark drones in
spider-man far from home and war machine
suit had a version of this in civil war
in this case it looks like a defensive
measure used against hulk powered
threats maybe she-hulk or titania then
we see this gang carrying some
interesting weapons crowbars hooks a
crossbow what kind of thread are they
facing if not a supernatural one like
vampires or werewolves there's an
eccentric mix of tones in this trailer
perhaps reflecting this series format as
a nine episode half hour legal comedy
with jen taking on a new case of the
week each week which all could showcase
a different aspect of the marvel world
vampires specifically have come up more
and more like in loki and eternals
eternals of course introduced blade in
its post-credit scene we saw a crossbow
in the sanctum undercroft and spider-man
no way home this october is going to be
werewolf by night halloween special
she-hulk just seems like a very apt
place to introduce these different
things this game may also be the
wrecking crew from the comics also known
for wielding crowbars or they could just
be another group of guys carrying weird
[ __ ] then we see a car wreck which might
be part of the inciting incident of
jen's transformation now in the comics
jennifer walters as a prosecutor
cracking down an organized crime ends up
getting targeted by the mafia in shock
leaving to her cousin bruce having to
give her a transfusion and that blood is
how she ends up getting her hulk powers
however later in this trailer jen
appears outside that car looking at the
dark reflection in the dented car door
and she already begins to transform so
maybe she got a transfusion before this
or it may just be innate to her family
dna perhaps activated by that shock wave
of gamma radiation when hulk snapped
everyone back in end game which is
something that hulk indicated the
radiation's mostly gamma
it's like uh
i was made for this so the uniqueness of
banner's blood that initially reacted to
the game of radiation in a specific way
to turn him into hulk may be the same
unique dna trait that is also in jen's
blood and now that everyone on earth has
been hit with game of radiation it just
caused her to react this specific way we
get a quick shot of jen's hulked out
physique in athletic gear we saw this in
the november teaser again i just love
how she's wearing the white purple and
black color scheme as she does in her
long time clothes in the comics moving
on
i'm jennifer welters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a superhuman law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
okay the marvel studios title card turns
a bright shade of green and it starts
from a little green flare of light from
beneath marvel suggesting that yeah it
might be a burst of gamma radiation that
was the cause of jyn's transformation
jen introduces us to her world and she
hangs out with a friend nikki played by
ginger gonzaga they have open wine
bottles all over the house and the wine
bottle to the right is the velvet devil
label stop putting devil fake outs in
all your trailers marvel you're just
making him angry hamilton's renee elise
goldberry plays amelia i'm assuming a
legal colleague of jennifer's in her
office is an hourglass because she's
obviously a tva agent please click away
if i don't at least mention these things
he punishes me but it's worth noting
that in the comics she-hulk represents a
variety of clients working one case in
front of the tva another time
representing eros in a sexual assault
case
probably not gonna be in the mcu josh
cigar plays another employee at this
firm we can see on the screen it shows
glk
h and the same design as the november
title card for this series that
thankfully now has been updated because
i like this new title way better glkh
stands for goodman lieber kurtzberg and
holloway which is the name of jen's law
firm in the 2004 run of the comics by
dan slott now the name goodman was a
reference to marvel publisher martin
goodman lieber a reference to stan lee's
actual last name stanley martin lieber
and kurtzberg a reference to jack
kirby's legal last name kurtzberg in the
comics these three partners are never
shown which is why their three letters
are grouped together holloway is the
only partner who jen deals with when jen
and nikki get shots jen's clothes are
actually she-hulk's color scheme once
again black blazer white shirt green
pants and purple light on her shirt then
we see this awesome new maximum security
facility located in the middle of the
desert with high perimeter walls and an
energy field fence on the drive-in this
interesting architecture makes me wonder
if this could be the mcu version of the
cube originally a shield black site in
the nevada desert designed to contain
gamma irradiated inmates and also became
the home base of the thunderbolts the
patches on the guards show a sigil of an
eagle carrying arrows that looks a lot
like the us department of justice but
this isn't the dodc that has a different
logo whereas sword was overseen by
hayward and now perhaps either monica
rambo or abigail brand maybe nick fury
the raft prison was overseen by
secretary of state thaddeus ross r.i.p
william hurt this agency may be under
the supervision of val someone we know
was involved in some shadowy government
agency and he could totally imagine
julie louie dreifus showing up in the
series back at the firm jen's supervisor
is holloway that being the same holloway
partner of this firm name and it sounds
like they're now branching out to handle
cases pertaining to superheroes the same
kind of legal work provided by matt
murdock in spider-man no way home now
while i imagine matt murdock would stick
to the new york area it's really only a
matter of time before these two marvel
lawyers cross paths so hopefully charlie
cox shows up on the show that'd be
awesome now holloway specifically wants
janet to be the face of the superhero
law division suggesting that this may
come about after her tendency to hulk
out emerges it looks like one of her
clients is emil blonsky aka abomination
tim roth returning from the 2008 hulk
film now remember abomination ended that
film getting ko'd by hope in the battle
of harlem and was actually later the
planned recruit by shield for one of the
avengers until we saw in that marvel one
shot coulson selvik used tony stark to
talk ross into recruiting bruce banner
instead blonsky was name-dropped in an
episode of ages of shields apparently
kept in a cold storage facility in
alaska and of course we last saw
abomination in chongqi sparring with
wong in the golden daggers club of macau
actually when wong opened that portal to
take abomination back the background
room showed that this is the same room
that he is now in in she-hulk now wong
is confirmed to appear in this series as
well so we'll likely get some answers to
why wong was partnered with abomination
in that movie was wong sneaking him out
or was this approved by the government
i'm wondering if these furloughs were
actually part of a deal to train up
abomination as a government soldier as
part of val's dark avengers crew maybe
alongside elena belova and john walker
maybe blonsky now what's out of that
deal and that's why he is now lawyering
up either way i hope we get some kind of
rematch between hulk and abomination in
the series i mean the road there let's
see the fight let them fight moving on
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still gotta deal with it okay
jennifer visits bruce in his new home on
this tropical coastline not sure where
exactly this is but later she-hulk wears
a shirt reading i heart mexico so this
may be along the mexican coastline like
the yucatan maybe one of the places
banner stopped during his journey from
brazil to the us in the 2008 film let's
not forget all of that happened in the
mcu even though it feels like so long
ago bruce pulls out a binder probably
containing his research that he
conducted over that 18 months of the
gamma lab then he mentioned an end game
when he found some mysterious cure to
reach his current balance and control
over his hulk abilities and he says you
didn't ask for this so it really does
sound like the series might be
suggesting jen's hulk powers could start
with a unique quality to their family
dna which is only now activated by a
recent burst of gamma radiation now
notice how the shots here are taken from
two different scenes one where hulk is
wearing a zip-up hoodie another where
he's wearing this t-shirt amazing that
he found one that bits him it's got an
interesting logo at first i thought this
could be related to shield but the bolts
emanating out of it made me wonder this
could actually be a logo that he made
for himself and his gamma radiation like
his new hulk logo and folks inflation is
hitting us all hard right now and that's
a great reason to start using upside an
incredible app for everyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out so all of us
pretty much with every purchase you can
earn cash back thanks to upside so
whenever i need to fill up my tank i
open up the upside app i search for a
nearby gas station offering a good deal
i claim it and then i head over to that
location and buy gas i can check in or
snap a pic of the receipt and then i'm
good to go no special cards to carry or
numbers to remember you can earn three
times more cash back than with credit
card rewards or loyalty programs you
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal or an e-gift card for amazon and
other brands upside users are earning
more than a million dollars every week
and it has a 4.8 star rating on the app
store so to get started download the
free upside app in the app store or
google play use the promo code new
rockstars to get five dollars or more
cash back on your first purchase of 10
or more and thanks again to upside for
sponsoring this video an app for which
there is only an upside now the second
scene looks like it is part of a
meditation session like he's like saying
relax breathe hulk could be teaching her
how to relax and center herself
meditation remember was a huge part of
bruce's regimen in the 2008 film now we
still do not know exactly why bruce was
shown in human form with his arm and a
sling in that shang-chi credit scene
especially now that he's back in hulk
for him with his arm completely healed
kevin feige told screenwrite that that
sling was intentional and i have
theorized that maybe hulk depowered a
human form to allow himself to give a
life-saving transfusion to jen but the
imax aspect ratio of that chiang chipos
credit scene showed banner was also on
his other arm wearing a piece of wrist
tech with a glowing green piece to it
which now after doctor strange and the
multiverse madness has come out kind of
reminds us of those 838 cuff links that
were powered by the green sand of
nisanti those sands depowering the
wearer for a certain amount of time
maybe wong gave banner that cuff to
depower him so that they could
temporarily heal his arm when he was in
human form because as whole his flesh is
otherwise so impenetrable they couldn't
really do anything to them let's move on
your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh i'm gonna die
yes yes yes
no
no okay down in the gamma lab again i
think this is the one hulk spent the 18
months in banner deliberately provodes
jen's anger with this torture device
their swim gear indicates that this lab
is underground their tropical mexican
home now where is in the november teaser
the screens beside banner showed jen's
face here it shows an x-ray of her brain
with the limbic system highlighted the
limbic system is the inner part of the
brain that controls emotion as banner
now says the hulk abilities are
activated by anger and fear we flashback
to jen's car accident transformation and
while she can't exactly see a reflection
fully the car paint is green which masks
her own skin color change and yeah we
see how this chamber is a total death
pod razor's spinning if you look closely
at those razors when she breaks them
especially you can see they are stark
industries brand so this means tony
stark may have helped banner set up this
gamma lab during those 18 months working
alongside him as a lab partner to help
him reach this wonderful smart hulk
state isn't that great and after these
razors successfully trigger the pier to
activate her she-hulk form banner gives
these thumbs up looking just as he did
to encourage the avengers during their
quantum experiment and end game and this
experiment is about as much of an
absolute win next clip i just want to be
a normal anonymous lawyer can you tell
us where she-hulk is jen you're a story
now
girl your ass looks crazy right now okay
we see jen in what looks like her
childhood bedroom there's a play poster
for shakespeare's midst of our night
stream which is a play all about
physical transformation and the sexual
arousal that arrives with it i assume
jen might relocate here after getting
some unwanted media attention due to her
condition then we see jen and her
she-hulk form trying to go about her
work routine but finds herself just
getting stared at even that receptionist
snaps a photo using the flash with all
this great natural lighting come on now
there's been a lot of chatter about the
unfinished cgi on she hulk and her face
in this trailer i think it was bound to
happen it honestly doesn't bother me as
much as it does some of you it really
only strikes me in this one shot of
jennifer looking at her phone it's not
so much the animation it's really just
the timing and the movement notice how
her eyes are slightly out of sync with
her body as it moves like i get it
they're trying to animate this gesture
of jen reacting to something on the
phone and then her eyes gesture to the
side like what do i do but they dart
adds her body is still straightening up
which just feels a little weirdly
unnatural like if you were animated in
cartoon you would do one move after the
other you have the back straighten and
then the eyes dart to the side and due
to the uncanny valley effect that is
encoded in our brains our minds just
weirdly accept more cartoony blocking as
more naturalistic which is why when you
watch pixar animation they deliberately
animate their characters to move more
cartoony and slapsticky because we grew
up watching cartoons our brains just
kind of accept that as natural that's
why they call it the uncanny valley you
have to go a little bit beyond what
would be natural movement so that when
we watch animated green characters we
just accept it i i see this as an
absolute win i will say i really
appreciate that they designed she-hulk
to have proportionately large hands
because remember hulk's fists are larger
than a human's hands would be compared
to the arms but the problem is you still
just don't get a sense of the weight of
the phone in her hands the way that they
showed the weight as hulk pinched the
tacos or clutch the sausage rolled in a
pancake look again none of this is that
big of a deal i don't think they are
still rendering all these effects ahead
of august and i definitely don't think
this is sonic level bad so let's just
all chill out okay and ultimately i just
applaud this series for leaning into the
tone of the character she-hulk and
especially the overt sexuality of the
character something that the comics do
not shy away from as shiok was really an
intentionally campy satire by the way
comics as a whole would over-sexualize
female superheroes she-hulk was really
the first female superhero to completely
own it and make it a joke this show
definitely seems to be embracing that
like the shot of all the gawkers at the
garden party the woman on the left is
the funniest to me like come on eyes up
here lady next clip
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
so jen burst out of her shoes as someone
tries to attack her from behind her
growth lifting him off his feet this
attacker wears an interesting helmet
that emits an energy glow not sure what
this is but it does remind me of the
advanced hardware that adrian toombs
crew lifted from shotari tech and
spider-man homecoming mickey encourages
her to join the avengers as we see
she-hulk and hulk leaping beside each
other on that island in a training
montage and while hulk hits a superhero
landing i like how jen does it she just
kind of lands in this less dignified
squat with her elbows beneath her knees
jen tells nicki that the avengers are
for billionaires and narcissists and
adult orphans referring to well i guess
tony stark who was all of those things
but also if you think about it
technically t'challa might be the
richest avenger if you quantify the
value of vibranium per ounce and peter
parker just lost the last of his
parental guardians he's kind of an adult
orphan who exactly are you throwing
shade at here jen and really any time
tatiana maslany says orphan one cannot
help but think of orphan black the
series where she showcased her amazing
talent then jen barefoot and closed torn
suggesting she was not prepared to hulk
out here tears across a damaged
courtroom toward a foe the other shot
reveals this is titania jamila jameel
mary mcferrin she hulks the longtime
nemesis in the comics now titania gets
powered up by alien technology and has
powers at rival gents it looks like
she's smashed into this courtroom maybe
to interrupt this trial keep someone
from testifying her outfit looks wild
something like a pro wrestler but then
there's a quick shot of this leaping
dude this is the fabulous frog man
eugene patillo one of the real goofball
marvel characters son of the leapfrog
vincent patio eugene takes on his dad's
frog costume he adds these spring coils
so that it can leap six stories in the
air he's shown up with spider-man the
human torch as well as the avengers of
various comics i just want to give a
huge congrats to long-time frog man stan
mt for frogman finally getting his mcu
debut i assume he will be another one of
jen's cases we get a quick shot of
abomination hulking out in his
containment cell ripping out of his
inmate jumpsuit as in shanghi the
character has been redesigned from the
2008 film to better match his comic
appearance he now has fins on the side
of his head and as he bumps his head the
red glow flashes over that container
self meaning this cell may be equipped
to shock him with pain whenever he tries
to hulk out of it then on to the last
clip is there anything more depressing
than dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
so jen swipes through a dating app on
her phone matcher and i like how she
swipes right on everyone and there's
some great easter eggs here of course
scott dog lover eight miles away grant
jump rope king 12 miles away oh you're
trying to be clever there grant nick dj
60 miles away noah director 24 miles
away nice scarf noah but my favorite is
truck local cutie 32 miles away not
exactly local but this is actually a
cameo by series creator jessica gao's
partner artist truck torrance and their
cat admiral whiskers truck and the cat
are wearing little captains hats to
salute the admiral so sweet of jessica
to get her local cutie in there now the
other names she swipes through that we
see from reverse are bryce charles chris
kevin feige and derek and then we see a
few of these dates including one guy who
flexes this is actually wwe wrestler
david ortunga but she ends the night
with his other hunk taking those fries
to go and we end with her carrying the
beefcake back to her room as his foot
knocks the lamp again folks a hard yes
to more sexual liberation rock hard yes
because otherwise this mcu until an
eternal sex scene was completely
puritanical we never got any sex in the
mcu sex is the normal part of adult life
it's okay to have it i'm super excited
for this series to come to the mcu on
august 17th you can support new rock
stars by checking out our merch options
at nirockstarsmerch.com comment down
below with your thoughts on all this
follow me on instagram and twitter ea
boss following the rockstars subscribe
to narc stars for more announcements of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you